hi this is Peter Russell of university
of story I also teach at UCLA in
Pepperdine but my main job is being a
story doctor in Hollywood and over the
last five years most of my work has gone
from working on movies to working on
television now when I began to work on
television five years ago more than
movies I kind of panicked because I'd
been working on films for 10 years and I
had developed a whole set of tools for
movies and I wasn't sure if I was even
gonna be able to help television
creators but the good news was
everything I'd learned about movies
worked in television everything the
television of course is different in
television the characters don't change
everything but the characters change and
the other thing is you can tell a lot
more than you show but all the patterns
I discovered that work in the genres and
movies also work in the genres of
television so what I wanted to talk to
you today a little bit about is how to
take a classic movie and to analyze it
and to break it down and we're gonna use
the Dark Knight to do so because all
these patterns gonna work in your
television show - the thriller patterns
and the action patterns I'm gonna talk
about today
work in television as well but and
because television is so full of dark
heroes now and even anti-heroes dark
heroes like mr. robot anti-heroes like
Breaking Bad I want and there's more
coming by the way many more anti he was
coming I want to talk to you about how
Chris Nolan who is a genius of a movie
maker has made an antihero in the show
dark night in the movie dark night that
is so brilliant that it shows you how
you can create an antihero not just in
movies if you want to make movies but
also in television I'm also gonna be
lecturing in a few weeks on how to turn
a great film into a television show
using Fargo as an example but I want to
use dark night tonight because Chris
Nolan is brilliant he's a genius and
nobody does the anti-hero story as well
as him now in action you want to
understand a couple of things in an
action movie the villains obvious you
see it from the very
getting and in okay so there's three
kinds of action heroes there is the
rites of passage hero who heals his
wound for the course of the movie this
is Iron Man there is the there is the
superhero this is Leonidas in 300 he
never really has an emotional change by
the way that can also be a villain
superhero like Jake Johnson in and Don
Jake's when he's a comic or it can be
the kind of villain that you have with
Jake Gyllenhaal in Nightcrawler he never
really changes
he just gets stronger and stronger as a
villain you also have a third kind of
action hero and that is the hero we're
gonna talk about today the antihero now
he's the guy who starts out good but
becomes evil for sympathetic reasons
this by the way is Walter White and
Breaking Bad and this by the way is
Harvey Dent in Dark Knight The Dark
Knight I'm using because Nolan is so
brilliant and antihero is simply a hero
who turns into a villain that's it you
want to use this kind of action hero if
you're writing a hip dark story with a
disturbing or provocative theme to
appeal to the hipster intellectual crowd
as well as the traditional action
audience so you get a mix it's brilliant
to do that we're going to show you this
hero in a movie I'm gonna logline the
movie for you right now now a movie
logline is about a hero who changes it's
the entire story of the movie from the
perspective of the hero but that's
exactly what you get here let me read
you the logline for Dark Knight when a
brave but self-righteous and wrathful
District Attorney is tapped by a
superhero to save a city from corruption
and a super villain he becomes so angry
at the supervillains hideous crimes that
he becomes evil himself and starts
murdering innocent people until the
super hero must step in kill him and
take the blame first crimes now who is
the hero in the Dark Knight it's not
Batman
it's Harvey Dent the DA but remember in
action the villain is insanely powerful
I just did a consult with a really
brilliant guy new rider very very big
actor who
wants to write and he wrote a brilliant
story but he left out his villain in a
lot of genres guys you want to have the
villain as the thing that drives all
your action even if you don't see it at
first and the Dark Knight has an
insanely powerful villain in the Joker
the hero is an antihero it's Harvey Dent
two-face Harvey Dent is a guy who starts
out good and he becomes evil and he does
so for reasons that we're gonna talk
about are the same reasons we voted
President Obama and office this is about
how the world works anti-heroes begin to
make the wrong decisions for the right
reasons because their core wound gets
activated by the villain he changes to
dark from light for sympathetic reasons
now Michael Corleone II and the
Godfather is an antihero why how does
Michael Corleone start out in the movie
he's a war hero and when he goes to his
father's house he tells his fiancee I'm
not like them Kay I'm different why does
Michael Corleone have become dark
sympathetic grizzlies remember what they
are why and Michael wants to save his
family this is the key secret to
creating a great antic you are guys make
him a guy we can care about if you don't
you end up with a really bad anti you
even know what he cares about so what do
we do that sir that's Anakin Skywalker
in Star Wars
okay great anti heroes now when you have
a action hero you want to give them
traits what are Harvey Dent traits in
this movie he's brave as hell he's a
risk taker
he's self-righteous and he's willing to
cut corners now where do we first see
him we see him in a courtroom fighting
against the corruption in Gotham City
with his fiancee at his sight and when
the guy on the stand pulls a gun on him
Harvey didn't just grabs the gun pulls
it out of his hand and tells the judge I
don't even want to take a break
I got a prosecute this guy and then I'm
gonna
play golf this afternoon and the whole
Court applauds why what is the power of
the Dark Knight because it's us you know
that Los Angeles is a corrupt city don't
you you know that our country has a lot
of corruption in it don't you
who's fighting it who's fighting it
nobody story vigilante
fighting it why is Batman important in
the story because Batman is a vigilante
fighting the corrupt forces of Los
Angeles fighting the corrupt forces that
give you a parking ticket for $900 that
get you into court and out for $4,000
when you know you did nothing wrong
bribery on every level how do we solve
it Harvey did we'll solve it he's
courageous righteous and good that's how
an ANA hero starts out he's using his
bravery for light but remember he's got
a core wound all great heroes do Harvey
Dent's core wound is that he his the the
people he loved died he can never love
now remember in this corrupt city Batman
is a vigilante and we see that in the
Batman television shows too when your
world is corrupt and every official you
meet is corrupt just like every cop
you're gonna meet in Los Angeles you're
probably gonna have a bad experience
with who do you turn to for salvation
you can't turn to a cop who do you turn
to maybe it turned to somebody you hire
who's a vigilante who's outside the
corrupt system well that's Batman
so in Dark Knight Batman decides to run
Harvey Dent for office he wants Harvey
Dent to come in and clean up Gotham City
because Batman is a vigilante can't do
it so what does he do
so when Bruce wayne/batman decides to
run Harvey Dent as the new District
Attorney Harvey Dent decides he will do
it but he doesn't in a disquieting
he says this city needs a Caesar needs
someone who's gonna come in and clean it
up regardless of the law now I ask you
guys most of you are Americans what
happened to our country after 9/11 what
did we all feel when we saw those planes
go into those towers we gotta get those
guys no matter what it takes no matter
what laws have got a break we got to get
those guys now I voted for President
Obama twice but President Obama sends
missiles to kill babies in the Middle
East every week why do we put up with
that if I could talk to him directly
what would he say to me he'd say Peter I
gotta do this yeah I know we're killing
innocent people but you want to be safe
don't you you don't want to know what we
have to do to keep you safe
but we gotta break the law guys this is
why the dark night is a brilliant story
because that's exactly what happens in
this story
Harvey Dent decides the evil is so bad
in the city that he's got to break the
law to do it so when he becomes powerful
as Batman's put him up here's what the
villain does the villain is so powerful
that he can walk into a group of
gangsters meeting and using a pin kill
one of their bodyguards and get away
with it and now the villains even more
powerful during a ceremony he has top
public officials killed and Harvey Dent
gets so angry at that that he pulls one
of the people aside one of the villains
cohorts and tortures him to get
information and when Batman shows up and
says you can't do it this way Harvey
you've got to obey the law you're part
of the law Harvey says but he's he's
evil and Batman says but he doesn't know
anything you're torturing him for no
reason he can't tell you what you want
to know so we already know and as we get
to the end of the first act that Harvey
Dent is unbalanced that even though he's
working for good his bravery has a
dangerous side to it and now here's
where the villain really deranged as
Harvey Dent he kidnaps Harvey Dent's
fiance Rachel and he arranges for Harvey
Dent to hear her being tortured and
killed
with gasoline now what would you do if
your fiancee was raped or murdered or
killed while you watched how would you
feel would you be able to say let's let
the law take care of that I don't think
I could so Chris Nolan's brilliance is
to show that Harvey Dent is deranged by
this horrible evil and Harvey Dent
himself is burned in the same accident
burn badly but he now turns evil because
he is so angry he begins to kill
innocent people
and as he kills innocent people he
becomes more and more out of control
until he finally kidnaps the
Commissioner of Police and the family
and is gonna shoot the child in front of
the commissioner now here's where the
theme of our movie is really important
remember I talked about theme a lot and
university of story what's the theme of
this movie
and what's the BMOC the theme of this
movie is this and it's classic and it's
used in platoon it's used in many war
movies
it's used over and over again it's used
in a story I'm working on right now that
we've created be careful when you fight
evil that you do not become evil
yourself that's the theme you would say
to President Bush to President Obama to
the American people today because as a
Hollywood liberal I would say we have
become evil in some ways we're creating
evil that's the theme of Syriana that's
the theme of many social problem dramas
and it's the theme here of this great
action movie be careful when you fight
evil that you do not become evil
yourself Batman is forced to rescue the
commissioner's family from Harvey Dent
and as he does so he must kill the
person that he brought in to bring
justice and law to the city and in the
final great sophisticated ending of this
dark hero and a hero's story Batman says
to the commissioner the people can never
know
that Harvey Dent became deranged I will
become the sacrificial goat they can
blame me because the people are not
strong enough to know the truth about
how we fight evil this is then exactly
what President Obama would tell me Peter
you don't want to see those pictures of
those dead babies in fact you can go on
google and see if you can see them you
won't because we must be protected our
leaders say by the very tactics that
we're used to keep us safe today this is
why a great action movie can also be a
great philosophical movie and Dark
Knight epitomizes this third type of
action hero the antihero it's a
brilliant story and it's a brilliant
story because it takes all the great
tools of action and puts it in service
of a great philosophical idea which
Chris Nolan always always does